pietre pietre pietre per tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj è
un secolo che non gioca bene a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti questo padova
vigente lo faccio per te se vuoi vai vai
a letto
no a metà pietro a metà ai fatti ed ha
poi parlato di ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io son of a bitch ei
matti neuronale persone
impossibile e comunque oggi siamo su
steve white con tom e pietro nel caso ne
foste accorti
vi lascio vito beh sì 6 no ma prova one
two three four no connection to the osso
meno male così non gioco con poi il
gioco da solo in video a giocare
impossibile no non voglio maledizione ma
se andiamo indietro sono da rispetto a
chi hanno detto e sosta tirando tocca le
cose sei fermo che nel centrare perché
messo random players cangemi telenova
invita a guardare centrando un ora gap
roba cosa invito a guardare non riesco a
entrare a giocare in ogni fa entrare ma
c'è uno che adorano rompere le palle o
tutto il bacino entriamo eccoti ora non
abbiamo il controllo cambia nome tom
anche tu pietro chiama chi sasso per
favore bravo ciao e grazie
se sei cambiato tutti e due donne e al
to say that sasso grazie ai partiti bene
non c'era ma non ci parla e ci accaniamo
la guarda ma ha detto vai sparagli
sparagli con la top a tom tom non è
altro che stavo mettendo il giovane fare
gli spari veloce più accadere
non posso non posso ma ora gli sparano
questa era talmente forte da poi la
mazzata che non si è neanche vista ecco
mi taglia stai fermo jap e casinò
malmenate vivo io sto a guardare
ciao lo so non mi prendessi o meglio che
ti ho sparato perché è meglio non ma
adesso come potevamo noi abbiamo perché
l'abbiamo invitato quest'uomo bastare
dov'era
sta vincendo thomas non ci ha mai
giocato ma sta fuori
dammi quella catalana
ma cosa che porta perde allora però la
presa pistola per una volta ho vinto in
una posata ballerina aia vai da pietro
ajax hi fi giu aspetta aspetta fermo
aliena no ti prego salvoni fare noi
ascona scusa marito io non c'è chi nato
alla fine che non guasta di che sia vero
ma capitoli perché stai migliaia o
grazie raga ma solo sul punto ci sono
pagati addosso ciao amici io vado a un
accosto visto st allagato tutto allagato
tutta milano grazie amico di reto regalo
per lui non sbagliatevi ha avviato
creato io
prima le c'è come porta menzione
capitano primo chi è questa se connesse
un vero se anche alla lega questo meno e
io sono morto dai fatelo far niente ha
vinto lui del russo che ha russo io io
son rosso basta ma rimaniamo fuori fuori
fuori
dietro ai malissimo pergusa globali cosa
vedo ciao ciao ciao sono esploso ma non
eri tu era il verde mia psiche mia no no
no no no sono morti
chi ha vinto dietro 20 conto va beh ecco
possiamo fare una roba
no non mi toccare vista non a me stava
vendendo bene si sta facendo loro aiuto
abbiamo da pietro dai ma non ce l'ho
fatta
ios serpente vi sta ammazzando si no
sono rimasta viva oddio mi sta tenendo
in vita il serpente ravellino se me ne
andavo giuro non ci sono più non
ricordare e tanaro la prenda non mi pare
la katana link
ma chi è questo verde aria o no no no no
no no
hey hey hey si ammazza e bella che non
ha ancora preso la presa e di tutto
questo io sono il tutto il resto io sono
dietro un cespuglio ayane è decollato
pietro di 30 cm ora scocciato la
pietraia aironi dall'inizio della
partita non mi caga nessuno
pietro via dietro aiutami a che brutto
questo gioco che brutto messaggio
qualche brutto questo gioco caduto e ha
vinto e tutto questo pietro come no no
no a pietro io sto prendendo solo in
camera nel male ti voglio bene
sei sempre stato un amico ho vinto io ho
vinto io
se la vita è bella
grazie sono fortissimo dopo quello che
hai avuto paura ora cava anche accusa
metodi uno per te uno per te ciao mi
piace giocare qui sotto o o si salva
grazie a tutti ai alan gross e l'urban
ragazzi a tutti ragazzi ciao amici bene
porca vacca
vabbè dai mi chiami dei peraltro
attribuito maker
da qualche parte nel mondo e mezzogiorno
e infatti ho vinto io ho questo problema
è che mai è quello senza lancia gli
amici ei ma che vale è il prendi pietro
per di pietro ma figurati pare non ci
speravo neanche ahia ahia vince sempre
thomas iniziato giocatori da tre minuti
e accesso gioco vince solo raja
no no no no no no no no no no no ma
toglie te ti ha dato un calcio forti
insomma lo ricorda ho vinto io
impossibile per una frazione di secondo
libro io ma non so com'è andato non sono
ancora morto mi dispiace ma stai lontano
la mia barca qui ho io avevo la pistola
ma ucciso lui se la cosa non certo non è
possibile davvero perché a alma pace
l'arma ma ci arriva ma vai via
le ditte che possa prendere levante armi
stanno cadendo la sopra falchi è mio
amico solo quando non c'è niente da fare
vi perdo no no no no no no la colla la
colla stick con la cosa che salta che
non si stacca l'ostia aiuto aiuto
basta spara le cose bianchi questa frase
questo non è di quelli a pagamento sono
morto io sono morto io non la gara
galera quasi un problema come ha fatto
tornare pidocchi macché vittoria che
vittori credibile che sarà la sono
sudata tre amici questa è proprio una
vita difficile a chi muore per l'ultimo
ragazzo senza sparare mai sentiti anche
muore per l'ultima senza sparare
ok io sto in mezzo a pietro togliti
no no no no non avete via con me ho
vinto io guarda che sono più magro è
quello fatto per caso cis e la sorpresa
occhio che quella roba lì non fa proprio
bene ok
mamma mia dove del fucile c'è la loro
che prendo la maglia parole praga mai
portare una spada al combattimento con
armi jolo
no ma mi sa che yacht tipo possa
spaccare spacciare questo terribile idea
non puoi spaccare niente aspettava si è
salvato seduta tra tante contempo gesù
ciao amici da dove sono finito fuori
cos'è sta roba oh mio dio cosa diavolo
fila sparato che figata
così ecco la gado di terzi è una cosa
che non dovete fare sparare alle catene
mi raccomando non fatelo queste quelle
oppure devo dire esattamente l'ho vinta
io picco io e caso parliamo ci si se la
chiamo c1 ma che alleanza fini da dio
pietro non serve a niente noi a
prescindere
no vai via
se tornar me l'hai mai perché ancora
vivo piano ecco il cav h
ma che cos max illegale non so cosa sia
qualcosa vedo 130 watt in garics animals
si voleva lavorare in alto ma non ci
sono riuscito manco per sbaglio ai
ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto ringrazio tom con una latenza
incredibile e pietro
è morto va bene ciao pietro abbiamo
iniziato il video
ciao se sarebbe iscritti scrive suicidi
mi piace lasci il canale di pietro e
thomas e descrizione si siede
cancelliamo proseguito da ragazzi
[Musica]